great and then the next the next second
XPrize selected work to come and talk to
us because they're kind of doing it
so the XPrize thing had like a range of
stuff we had he's kind of disease things
in Africa there was like medical devices
and other kinds of all kinds of systems
and elysium tell us with our work with
opiate relapse assistants
hi so I'm the co-founder and CEO of
behavior and my co-founder Rhino chase
down there and I will introduce you to
what we're working on so what if you
could use wearable technology behavior
change techniques and artificial
intelligence to help solve one of
society's biggest problems imagine if
you could detect in advance that someone
trying to stay sober from opioids had a
higher likelihood of relapsing going
back to using and imagine if you could
detect when someone overdoses to allow
for life-saving treatment to be
administered before it's too late
this would allow EMS to come or a member
of their support network
so we've created a software platform to
predict and prevent opioid relapses and
overdoses using wrist wearables and AI
to provide the right intervention at the
right time in real time currently 30
million individuals are struggling with
substance misuse according to the
substance abuse and mental health
services administration in the US and
almost 12 million of them have opioid
misuse this number is even larger based
on the families that are also being
affected once individuals enter
treatment some facilities offer 30 days
but longer stays proved to be more
effective and the relapse rate for
heroin is 90% so as many of you know
drug addiction is a growing problem
particularly with opioids and recently
drug overdose deaths in the u.s.
surpassed 72 thousand per year that's
higher than the peak deaths of
automobile accidents HIV deaths and gun
violence and it's not just the u.s. this
is a global problem and this doesn't
discriminate by zip code income or
career globally 240 million people are
dependent on alcohol more than a billion
people smoke tobacco products and about
15 million people use injection drugs
such as heroin
so the according to the US Surgeon
General the cost of addiction is four
hundred forty two billion dollars a year
so this includes lost productivity
criminal justice costs and health care
costs so it's significantly impacting
everyone regardless of whether or not
they or someone they know is struggling
with addiction for employers this
includes lost productivity and a
diminishing work force and this also
costs governments and taxpayers through
recidivism and criminal justice costs
many people go through painful
withdrawal
in prison and they're left with little
to no medical or psychological support
and then shortly after they relapse
usually within about three months the
emergency response times are greatly
impacted in some areas with EMTs going
from overdose call to overdose call
meaning that their resources are
stretched really thin and care can be
delayed sometimes with disastrous
results this also contributes to the
rising health care costs and the strains
on our system so when looking at this
problem from a design perspective my
team and I started small we sat in a
room for hours with our brains a
whiteboard and as usual too few color
options for markers we used our
expertise and unique unique life
experiences to craft a solution focused
on empowering individuals struggling
with addiction to change their behavior
with the support of technology we then
spoke to people and organizations that
are most affected by relapses and
overdoses to find out what their pain
points are and how and if our idea could
solve those so historically the tools
used to keep people sober and stay sober
have been reactive rather than proactive
they provide help after people start
using again or after they overdose and
we have to think about what about the
individuals who don't have the resources
to afford the time space and access to
high-level full-service treatments how
do they manage their recovery access to
treatment needs to be democratized and
unfortunately today is it is not so
today is a new era of proactive relapse
prediction wearable smart phones and
artificial intelligence have all
recently evolved and we're now able to
detect that someone trying to stay sober
is in what we call a red alert craving
obsession state so this allows us to
intervene with the right support at the
right time in real time so how does this
work through the use of AI we can
psychologically impact behavior change
by providing relevant and crucial data
to help maintain long-term sobriety and
a healthier recovery process we will
detect a number of factors such as heart
rate stress levels and GPS location so
our proposed solution for detecting a
craving state and initiating a
just-in-time intervention requires
processing multiple real-time sensor
feeds through adaptive machine learning
models our model will examine among
other data sources the user's
physiological data as a time series and
after filtering out noisy artifacts from
sensor data in normalizing for the users
baseline physiology the model will
predict a craving state and I'm gonna
give you a hypothetical example now so
meet ami ami recently finished a 28-day
stay at an inpatient treatment facility
because that's all her insurance would
cover this is a u.s. problem so a few
weeks later her father passed away
now her sleeps off she's smoking more
cigarettes than usual she's skipping her
support group meetings she has a racing
heart and she's getting jittery and
sweaty she can't stop thinking about
using again based on her physiology and
behavior we tell Amy that her patterns
resemble a drug craving obsession state
and then we ask her does she want to do
anything about it
Amy chooses to set up a supportive
message and photo in phone call in
advance and it's a photo of her daughter
and the message says I don't want to
lose you again I love you we then
connect her to her 12-step sponsor and
she's able to make it through this
relapse mode state without relapsing the
beauty of our technology is that
interventions can be completely
customized in advance
to do or whatever people know will help
them most in their time of need and
we're utilizing strategies from
behavioral economics motivational
interviewing and cognitive behavioral
therapy to help nudge people towards
positive behavior change will also
detect overdoses to give quicker access
to life-saving medications like naloxone
so we can see this in action if the
video works ok the video is not gonna
work so I'll just go through the slide
images so this is our web application
which it is working ok we're working on
now so it just has a basic UI for
testing so please forgive the aesthetics
and in this case we're logging in as Amy
so this is what our dashboard looks like
and here you can see that Amy set a
reminder for her next appointment
and what we really wanted to do was
build in contacts to the support system
because that's been shown through
research to be very effective in terms
of motivations so for example Amy can
complete the motivational tool here for
her medications and then she'll see a
reward she can also send a text to her
support team who are listed here and
here's an example of the message that
has been sent Amy is just completed a
five-day streak these are tools that
make it easy to incorporate a social
support system and we did want to make
this as user centered as possible since
we did not know since we know that
opioid addiction it's a very personal
and private affair so we wanted to make
sure that the the option to hide and
unhide information as you seek it from
the little eyeballs they're under vitals
so we can see that there's heartrate and
sleep and incidents things such as heart
rate panic attacks and sleep problems
could be issues that are coexisting with
addiction there's a lot of comorbidity
with other mental health issues so we
wanted to build in the possible
for Amy to take action on this
information right away such as by
letting dr. Grayson know here that
they're been sleeping issues and perhaps
to schedule an appointment again these
are things that we can hide and make
sure Amy is comfortable with the privacy
of her information on on this next panel
I'm just gonna skip through the video we
can see that there are trigger updates
Amy can see if there's been contact with
a problem person and she has the option
to block calls it shows the location of
available in the locks own kits nearby
and these can save a life by reversing
an overdose she can also pull up a map
with immediate directions to the nearest
locations and again we're making it
easier to reach out to someone's 12-step
sponsors therapists and more and if Amy
doesn't have a support group because not
everyone is is lucky enough to have a
built-in social safety net we have the
option to find additional resources so
this wearable platform technology won't
be a sole means for coping with
addiction it will augment it making
other evidence-based treatments more
powerful like yo-yo ma just said it's
all hands on deck with this problem we
are facing and we can boost the efficacy
of existing tools like medication
assisted treatment cognitive behavioral
therapy support groups and 12-step
programs our goal is to be a guardian
angel on your wrist to help when people
might not be motivated enough to help
themselves on their own and quickly more
about us um we're in the top 10 for this
milestone of the IBM Watson AI XPrize
competition and we're a graduate of
alpha lab a startup accelerator we're
currently participating in the National
Science Foundation's innovation core
program which is focused on accelerating
the economic and societal benefits of
emerging technology among many other
things where else we've also recently
been awarded a grant from the National
Institute of
health and its funding an IRB approved
study that we're conducting with our
partners Jade Wellness with machine
learning being conducted through our
partnership with the University of
Washington and with researchers from
Carnegie Mellon University we're also
conducting a wearables three-phase
clinical research study as well and we
won two hackathons recently the social
justice innovation weekend and the
opioid hackathon in California
let's see you skip through we're
collaborating with Kevin Stephens an NHL
player that's really cool I'm just gonna
skip through these quickly because we're
almost out of time I'm a UI UX designer
my co-founder Ryan reach researches the
implications of emerging emerging
technology and has start-up experience
and we're collaborating collaborating
with a number of very smart people so
this is larger than opioids and larger
than addiction imagine being able to use
this pattern detection AI and
intervention technology to empower
individuals to change any unwanted
behavior on their terms in a way that
works best for them so this could be
anything from PTSD suicidal ideation
other addictions and even overeating and
healthy food choices if we can
successfully tackle this opioid
challenge it can be used for other
life-saving solutions as well with AI
and human centered design we can keep
people more engaged in their recovery
process and more empowered to help
themselves in a way that works best for
them
rather than leaving recovery to chance
we can in a secure way use AI and
wearable technologies to add a valuable
tool to the recovery tool belt so it's a
user experience challenge and we want to
code a shortcut path for them to walk
down to make their recovery a little
easier thank you for your time
great thanks a lot so if there's time
for one question we probably could
well of course data protection is really
important we we file follow HIPAA
regulations which requires very
stringent data security to protect
people who are patients currently we're
working with folks who are an outpatient
treatment so we have protections in
place to make sure that everything's
good and they also everyone owns their
own data ok a little question while
they're setting up about if you if
you've looked into anything where you
you've got the models and that a
prediction of whether they're gonna
relapse are you gonna have any feedback
like a feedback into your model say well
they found this useful or not and have
it learn and update over time from each
user
absolutely yeah we want we we want
everything to be every every data point
will be used to help make it more
effective
so even when people relapse which is a
normal part of recovery that will add a
data point to show us if maybe what were
what other interventions might work
better and where that happens in in that
stage of recovery
okay great things to think Ellie thank
you all so much have a good time
[Applause]